Quality reporting is a particularly
interesting and challenging area
generally done by reporting
process and/or outcome measures.
While outcome measures
are usually preferable,
we often don't have
practical ones available.
Hemoglobin A1c is a test
done on a blood sample
that can serve both as a process and
an outcome measure for diabetes care.
Hemoglobin, the red stuff in your blood
cells, is the oxygen carrying molecule.
The level of its A1c variant tracks with
the amount of glucose out in the blood.
Glucose is the molecule that is not
properly regulated in diabetes.
So the more that's out of the blood,
the more of it that enters
the red blood cells.
The more glucose in the cells,
the higher the A1c level.
As we can see here,
not much glucose, a low A1c level.
Lots of glucose, an unhappy red blood
cell because its A1c is very high.
But this increase occurs over time,
so hemoglobin A1c is proportional
to the average blood glucose level
over the prior couple of months.
This is great, since the goal of
diabetes therapy is to keep the same
average glucose level within
normal ranges over time.
As you can see here,
the blood glucose levels go up and
down depending upon what's eaten,
exercise and other factors.
However, it may go up and
down here the hemoglobin A1c
level remains constant at 7,
indicating good control.
In fact, good control is defined as
an A1c under 9 by most organizations,
but the highly regarded Mayo Clinic
uses this number 7 as its benchmark.
Which of these would be
an outcome measure for diabetes?
Recording of key data, testing for
HbA1c level on a regular basis,
a HbA1c level under 9?